esta vez tengo tres funciones aquí las
cuales todas se llaman f pero vamos a
suponer que son funciones distintas y
para cada una de estas tres funciones
que tengo aquí lo que quiero hacer es
encontrar primero los ceros déjame
ponerlo aquí queremos encontrar los
ceros y recuerda que un cero o dicho de
otra manera una raíz es aquel valor que
hace la función igual a cero entonces
por ejemplo para esta función que tengo
aquí los ceros serán los valores de t
que hagan
efe igual a cero para la siguiente
función van a ser los valores de x en
esta ocasión que hagan la función f x
igual a 0 y bueno de estas tres quiero
encontrar sus ceros también lo segundo
que quiero encontrar es las coordenadas
del vértice así que déjame ponerlo aquí
también queremos encontrar el vértice
vértice de cada una de estas tres
funciones y bueno por último lo que
también voy a querer encontrar
es el eje de simetría el eje de simetría
para cada una de estas tres funciones y
de hecho va a ser una línea que va a ser
única para cada una de estas tres
funciones entonces es buen momento para
que pause el vídeo y vea si puedes
averiguar los ceros el vértice y el eje
de simetría para cada una de estas así
que intenta lo bueno suponiendo que ya
lo hiciste ahora vamos a hacerlo juntos
pero eso sí si en cualquier momento te
inspiras de nuevo pausa el vídeo y sigue
trabajando porque recuerda la mejor
manera de aprender todo esto es
haciéndolo por ti mismo muy bien vamos a
trabajarlo juntos y lo primero que vamos
a hacer es encontrar los ceros para esta
primera función así que veamos para qué
efe dt sea igual a cero en esta función
de amarillo lo que tiene que pasar es
que te menos 5 al cuadrado menos 9 sea
igual a cero déjame escribirlo
-5 esto elevado al cuadrado menos 9 esto
tiene que ser igual a cero ahora bien si
sumo nueve de ambos lados de esta
ecuación que voy a obtener voy a obtener
que te menos 5 esto elevado al cuadrado
tiene que ser igual a 9 porque estoy
sumando 9 de ambos lados y ahora sí
tengo t menos 5 al cuadrado igual a 9
esto es exactamente lo mismo que pensar
que te menos 5 que te menos 5 sea igual
a la raíz cuadrada positiva de 9 que es
3 o en su dado caso que te menos 5 que
te menos 5 sea igual a la raíz cuadrada
negativa de 9 que es menos 3 y ahora
para obtener atem lo que puedo hacer es
sumar 5 de ambos lados y voy a obtener
de este lado que te es igual a 8 o bueno
en su dado caso si tengo esta ecuación
de aquí y sumó 5 de ambos lados
llegar a que te va a ser igual a menos
35 lo cual es 2 así que te iguala 8 o te
iguala dos son los valores de terna que
hacen que ft sea igual a cero es decir f
de 8 va a ser igual a 0 y f2 también va
a ser igual a 0
ahora bien ya que tenemos los ceros pues
vamos a pensar en el vértice para esta
función es más déjeme notar lo voy a
buscar el vértice el vértice y bueno
para eso vamos a pensar en la mitad del
camino que hay entre los dos ceros de
esta función
efe dt voy a buscar la coordenada t en
este caso que va a estar a la mitad del
camino donde la parábola intersecta al
eje bueno al eje en este caso dicho de
otra manera es la mitad del camino entre
8 y 2 así que el vértice lo vamos a
encontrar entre el promedio entre 8 y 2
es decir 8
2 esto dividido entre 2 o lo que es lo
mismo eso es igual a 5 estás de acuerdo
aquí me quedaría 5 es el valor de tm de
mi vértice y ya que tengo el valor de t
cuánto vale ft bueno pues efe de 5
serían 5 menos 5 esto es 0 al cuadrado
es 0 menos 9
entonces me quedaría el valor de menos 9
el vértice está en el punto 5 menos 9 y
tiene mucho sentido porque está que
tenemos aquí es una ecuación ordinaria
de la parábola donde fácilmente podemos
ver dónde está su vértice es como la
ecuación escrita en una forma muy buena
para encontrar el vértice el vértice es
fácil de reconocer porque el vértice es
el valor mínimo que podemos tomar y por
eso esta parte de aquí la tenemos que
hacer igual a cero porque observa como
entendemos algo elevado al cuadrado
pequeño que se puede hacer esto elevado
al cuadrado es cero porque no podemos
tomar valores negativos de algo que se
está elevando al cuadrado por lo tanto
cuando esto se hace cero el valor mínimo
que podemos tomar en nuestra función es
el valor de menos 9 es decir no sumarle
nada a menos 9 y para que esto se haga 0
entonces éste tiene que tomar el valor
de 5 muy bien y ya con toda esta
información que te parece si hacemos un
pequeño bosquejo para ver qué es lo que
está sucediendo por aquí así que manos a
la obra déjame ponerlo así voy a tener
por aquí mi gente por aquí tengo mi eje
t y bueno por aquí por aquí me voy a
tomar a mi eje de déjame escribirlo este
de aquí va a ser mi eje t es importante
mencionarlo porque lo estoy olvidando ni
ejtm y por aquí tengo mi eje bien muy
bien y primero fijémonos en el vértice
el vértice tiene como coordenadas 5
menos 9 así
y por aquí tengo el valor de 5 en temps
y por aquí tengo el valor de menos 9 en
que entonces nivel se estaría justo por
aquí recuerda estamos viendo la gráfica
james igual a efe dt y si ya tenemos el
vértice bueno también me puedo fijar en
los ceros de esta función míseros eran
el valor de t igual a 8 que va a estar
como por aquí aquí tengo el valor de t
igual a 8 y t igualados aquí tengo el
valor de t igual a 2 y observa la
distancia que hay de 2 a 5 es la misma
distancia que hay de 5 a 8 y ahora sí
podemos graficar esta función
efe de esta función efe dt con estos
tres puntos se va a ver más o menos algo
así se va a ver más o menos
o así y algo más o menos
y bueno esta será la gráfica de la ftm
ahora lo último que queremos encontrar
es el eje de simetría pero recuerda el
eje de simetría es simplemente la línea
vertical que pasan a través del vértice
mi eje de simetría va a ser esta línea
vertical que estoy poniendo justo en
este momento y si te das cuenta esta es
la línea de igual a 5 de igual a 5 y
observamos realmente quién define el eje
de simetría es la coordenada t del
vértice en este caso toma el valor de 5
bien ahora trabajemos los otros dos
ejercicios que tenemos aquí así que
trabajemos a este y lo primero que
quiero obtener son los ceros y para
obtener los ceros voy a decir que x + 2
x x + 4 eso va a ser igual a cero déjame
ponerlo así
x + 2 x 2 que multiplican a x + 4 esto
tiene que ser igual a cero ahora bien
para que esto sea igual a cero eso
quiere decir que x + 2 tiene que ser
igual a 0 o x + 4 tiene que ser igual a
cero déjame escribirlo o x + 2 es igual
a cero o en su dado caso x + 4 esto es
igual a 0 en el primer caso me queda que
x es igual a menos 2 este va a ser un
cero de mi función
fx y en el segundo caso me queda que x
es igual a menos 4 y así tengo el
segundo de los ceros muy bien ahora
pensemos en el vértice para obtener el
vértice lo que nos íbamos a fijar es en
la mitad del camino entre los dos
valores que tenemos que nos dan los
ceros de la función así que vamos a
sacar el promedio de menos 2
más menos 4 esto a su vez dividido entre
2 pero bueno menos dos menos cuatro es
lo mismo que menos 6 entre 2 es menos 3
así que en lugar de todo esto
voy a poner simplemente menos 3 muy bien
menos 3 es el valor que toman x en el
vértice es nuestra coordenada x del
vértice y cuál va a ser nuestra
coordenada james bueno pues vamos a
sustituir menos tres más dos es menos
uno me quedaría menos uno que multiplica
a menos 34 eso es 1 que multiplica a 1
entonces menos uno por uno eso
simplemente es menos 1 así que ya está
aquí tenemos el vértice y si pienso en
mi eje de simetría bueno como ya vimos
eso es muy fácil mi eje de simetría base
es la línea vertical que pasa por el
vértice en este caso va a ser la línea
vertical x igual
-3 ahora ya que tenemos toda esta
información vamos a hacer un pequeño
esbozo por acá abajo para ver qué es lo
que está pasando
así que por aquí me voy a tomar a mi eje
x voy a suponer que este es mi eje x y
bueno por aquí me voy a tomar mi eje y
que lo voy a poner más o menos por aquí
porque casi todo lo que tenemos es
negativo muy bien este va a ser mi eje y
este de aquí va a ser mi eje
y ahora si nos fijamos en los ceros de
esta función
estamos en menos dos y en menos cuatro
en x así que para cada me voy a tomar
menos 1 - 2 - 3 y por acá menos 4 ok y
en y bueno me estoy fijando en el valor
de menos 1 así que por aquí tengo menos
1 en 10 y ahora los ceros de esta
función están en menos 2 y menos 4 - 2
-4 por otra parte el vértice está en el
menos 3 - 1 - 3 - 1 es decir estoy justo
por aquí déjame ponerle este es menos 2
este es menos 4 y entonces mi parábola
se va a ver más o menos así esta va a
ser la gráfica de mi función
james es igual a efe
déjame notarlo esta es la gráfica de mi
función
james es igual a efe
ya que tenemos este bosquejo vamos a
hacer el último de nuestros ejercicios
de este vídeo y bueno lo primero que
vamos a querer es obtener los ceros de
esta función
así que fx tiene que ser igual a cero lo
que quiere decir que x cuadrada más 6x
más 8x cuadrada más 6x más 8 esto tiene
que ser igual a 0 y ahora tenemos esta
expresión igualada 0 bueno pues se me
ocurre que debe de ser fácilmente factor
isable y si no lo es para ti recuerda
que puedes revisar los vídeos acerca de
factorización de polinomios y bueno lo
primero que se me ocurre es en dos
números que multiplicados me den 8 y
sumados me den 6 bueno de hecho son 4 y
2 esto es lo mismo que x + 4 que
multiplican a x + 2
esto igual a 04 por 2 s 8 y 42 6 y ahora
observa estamos hablando del mismo
polinomio que tenemos a la izquierda
aquí tengo un x + 2 aquí tengo un x + 2
un x + 4 un x + 4 eso quiere decir que
estamos hablando de la misma función
estas dos son la misma función
simplemente están escritas de una manera
distinta por lo tanto si son la misma
función vamos a llegar a la misma
gráfica que tengo aquí eso quiere decir
que todas las soluciones serán
exactamente las mismas estas dos
funciones son iguales y por lo tanto
tienen el mismo vértice en el mismo eje
de simetría los mismos ceros la misma
gráfica y entonces todo será exactamente
igual excepto que están escritas de
maneras distintas